we've got a lot of [ __ ] dumb smart
people in this country and a
disproportionate number of them worked
for Hillary Clinton in 2016 we have this
layer of elites on top of the society
that's crumbling in my opinion but
because the folks at the top are
insulated from this and the
disintegration it doesn't matter and one
of the things that makes me really sad
is that I think a couple decades ago if
you were smart and savvy and hustled and
good with people like there were all of
these paths open to you that didn't
involve your SAT score now if you're
just like a good person and hardworking
and have some savvy and people skills
you may not actually be able to live a
sustainable middle-class life
[Music]
I remember sitting with van and learning
about his backstory and all that he went
through from his family on up and it's
incredible that guy has an arc you would
not believe and and even after he you
know quote-unquote made it
he had this somewhat fall from grace
when he left the White House and then he
ended up working for Prince who's like
you know super hero in my mind so his
ups and downs are incredible but really
the most incredible things like his
Genesis they're coming up out of rural
Tennessee and winding up working on the
coasts after getting kind of sucked up
into the like the elite institutions you
talk about something that you've coined
and we're gonna define here and you coin
it dumb smart people um why don't you
define that for what you mean when you
say we have a lot of dumb smart people
in this country we have a lot of people
who succeeded academically who have a
very very limited sense of how the world
functions ya know that there's something
I said in my book and I'm just going to
crimp from and quote from myself
pause quote the great danger game yes to
quote myself so I I wrote a chapter
called life in the bubble and it talks
about people who are highly educated and
here's my list of of things about them
that make them a little bit less right
on in terms of judgment so people in the
bubble think that the world is more
orderly than it is the over-plan they
mistake smarts for judgment they mistake
smarts for character
the overvalued credentials had not heart
they need status and reassurance they
see risk is a bad thing they optimize
for the wrong things they think in two
years not 20 they need other bubble
people around they get pissed off when
other succeed theirs they think their
smarts should determine their place in
the world they think ideas supersede
action they get agitated if they're not
making clear progress they're unhappy
they fear being wrong and looking silly
they don't like to sell they talk
themselves that I having guts they
worship the market they worry too much
bubble people have their pluses and
minuses like anyone else so that that
was my description of dumb smart people
shall we say you know and I read a book
by Chris Hayes called called twilight of
the elites that actually hit a lot of
the same themes where we have a set of
elites who've been acculturated and
trained in certain ways and it makes
them excellent at optimizing and certain
tasks and terrible at lots of other
things and it also breeds the empathy
out of you it like gives you this fake
empathy like can wave and be like oh I
feel so bad about that problem but then
they're they're actually put in position
where they started taking the problem
for granted so I saw this when I got the
Duke so like I on paper I'm you know as
a straight white dude with from Canada
kid worked on Wall Street so there's
there's certain assumptions about that
but I didn't come from a lot of money so
when I got to Duke I saw these kids that
went to the deer fields and the Roxbury
Aladdin's knees prep school was very
very intimidated but a lot of them had
it was like it wasn't that they couldn't
work har was more like a sense of
entitlement and I remember like going to
study groups in them and they're goofing
off and I was like man these kids must
be so smart and then they wouldn't get
good grades which always pissed me off
because it you know from my public
school
in Elmwood Connecticut and near Hartford
like there was a whole list of kids that
would have killed to go to an elite
school and you know taking econ testing
and try harder on it but these kids at
the end of the day you know they're
working now they're working at the
private Bagby firm the law schools you
know into politics and they're making
more money than all of us and the other
people can be running the country
someday I think that's what you and van
talked about is that that Lane not only
is that these people are called dumb
smart people but then they end up being
in leadership positions down the road
yeah I mean van talks about it where
when he showed up to Yale Law they were
like your guys are gonna end up being
senators and vans like are you kidding
me and then it turns out fast forward 25
years some of them are senators so it
you know that like and there's something
messed up about the fact that they could
say that with such confidence and be
right it's really the problem I mean we
we have this layer of elites on top of
the society that's crumbling in my
opinion but because the folks at the top
are insulated from this in the
disintegration it doesn't matter
and and then there's this thrashing
around where people are trying to figure
out what's going wrong and that's what's
going wrong it's like well your fortunes
are not tied to ours and so as our lives
disintegrate you're looking around being
like what is the problem why are people
upset like why is this not working you
know why aren't you magically getting
educated for the jobs of the future even
though we've made that ridiculously out
of reach and now you know the jobs of
the future are few and far between so
there there are all of these disconnects
that I think my conversation with Vann
actually highlights yeah and there's
these two types of smarts where it's
like the one smart is you're smart
enough to be a hedge fund analyst on
Wall Street or work at a big law firm
and then there's this other type of
smart where you can run a successful
family car repair shop or run it
[ __ ] business or be a hairdresser and
kick-ass and I think what's been
interesting about kovat is like we're
learning what's more essential right now
when I was growing up they called it
street smarts you know and one of the
things that makes me really sad is that
I think a couple decades ago if you were
smart and savvy and hustled and good
with people
like you could build a successful
restaurant bar car repair shop you know
flower shop hardware store like what
have you you know they're like a million
paths up you could be coming you could
become a professional salesperson and
live a fine life and there were all of
these paths open to you that didn't
involve your SAT score frankly right and
then now that's less and less true where
now if you're just like a good person
and hard-working and have some savvy and
people skills you may not actually be
able to live a sustainable middle-class
life because that's just the way our
economy has evolved it's just squeezed
out more and more opportunities and so
now if you're that upward leaning person
like your best hope is to try and get
close to a geyser it's like ooh maybe I
can somehow finagle my way into like
Amazon or one of these like giant tech
firms and then from there if I you know
like it can impress people or keep my
head down then like huh then like that's
my path to a decent life you know that
there was one story I heard that was
like the most heartbreaking thing where
there was a guy who ran a chain of like
mom-and-pop grocery stores in New Jersey
Amazon bought Whole Foods and so then
this New Jersey grocery store owner was
like well we're screwed we're gonna lose
to these guys so I now we'll just use
all my earnings to buy Amazon stock as
opposed to investing in my grocery store
chain you know I heard that story and I
was like yeah that that's actually in a
way pretty smart or wise but we're still
maintaining the fiction
that you can go out and start your
grocery store in your neighborhood and
it's gonna be fine even as you're
getting squeezed from both ends so you
and I we stopped at this lot on the
trail and we thought about lot
personally just in like individual
conversations we both hate this right we
hate what does our friends we hate what
does door world hey what does to the
working people around the country how
would you it's obviously bigger than one
solution but what would you do what
needs to be done to fix this or at least
start getting us trending the right
direction because we're trending the
opposite right like this is getting
worse not better
what would you do fix it what I would do
is put buying power into the hands of
everybody and if you look at a town that
has a college in it you see all these
small businesses and cute stores and
like you know karate studio and like
yoga classes and and all this stuff we
can make more of our towns look like
that it just people have buying power
because if you have buying power there
are certain things that the tech
company's going to deliver to your door
and you know there's no stopping it but
there are certain things that you'd want
to experience you know in your town like
a bakery or why not it's like maybe you
just would like to have fresh baked
goods and so buying power in our hands
actually helps keep the economy closer
to home because those things aren't
going to be economically competitive
they're just going to be competitive in
terms of quality of life and so that
that's actually the way that we can
really rejuvenate opportunities and
entrepreneurship for people because
there are people listening to this right
now who have imagined like oh maybe I
should open up whatever it is you name
it bed and breakfast yoga studio
nonprofit whatever it is and those
things are not realistic for many many
people but they become much more
realistic if number one you have
Economic Security yourself because
you're getting some form of income you
can rely on and number two there's a lot
more money flowing around your
unity then all of these things become
more possible particularly if people are
willing to pay an extra buck or two
because you know they like your muffins
or they write there are certain things
that you know they're willing to just go
to in person
now the coronavirus obviously
complicates this because a lot of the
value add to being in person now in like
let's say a yoga studio has disappeared
right and so will that come back we're
we don't know and this to me is one of
the major problems for entrepreneurship
and small businesses over the coming
months and years that a lot of those
value propositions that mom-and-pop
entrepreneurs rely upon is the fact that
you're being physically proximate is
something you want and if you really
don't want that then a lot of this stuff
goes out the window
so that's painful but it starts with
people having enough money to spend if
you destroy the middle class of a
country guess what you get rid of all
those things that serve the middle class
you know that there's so you need a
middle class to have that kind of
opportunities that you want so that it
isn't necessary for us all to go apply
to work at Amazon I'm gonna shift gears
a little bit in that vein no talking
about reopening the economy so I think I
disagree with you on this Andrew so
right now you've got la saying close
forever New York saying stay close and
Florida opening up in different states
doing different things should we be
opening up cuz and here's my thought is
that Weaver told stay home because we
need to flatten the curve and I think by
most objective numbers the curve is
flattening and hospital beds have space
now so what's the downside of reopening
right now why can't we start getting
things back to normal before we have
irreversible damage the economy I think
we should be reopening parts of the
economy in the country judiciously based
upon what's going on in those
communities the reality is we can't stay
indoors and just wait forever for a
vaccine that is months and months
way so you have to start making harder
choices now and that involves which
states might be safe to reopen which
parts the economy might be safe to
reopen which places of work and
institutions to me the big missing piece
that we really can and must do a much
better job on is testing because then
you look up and say okay should Arkansas
reopen and then you're like well what
data points are we relying upon mainly
hospital admissions and then you say
well is that indicative of what's going
on in our communities to some extent yes
but you know would be a much better
indication of what's going on in our
communities people taking tests you know
seeing people taking antibody tests
right so so that to me is something that
would be an enormous value add but it's
going to be time for us to start making
difficult policy choices because it's
not realistic to just say everyone stay
inside until a vaccine arrives and there
are real trade-offs where it's true that
businesses and people if you have them
on the bench for too long will lose a
lot of jobs and economic productivity
plus you know a lot of these
organizations are doing very important
things not just the essential but like
the things that are one step below
essential I think this is it's very hard
trade-off between obviously the cost of
human life or the cost of people getting
sick what else like rotavirus also sucks
if you don't die right so there's also
just like a personal pain that comes
with getting it but what do you say
there's this trade-off between opening
the economy and that pain what do you
say to my grandmother right who's
terrified to go outside and when people
are like let's open the economy let's
open the economy like how do you and
especially as a leader how do you
navigate that and and message that in a
human way I think your grandmother is
right to be concerned and
I think that if you are part of a
vulnerable high-risk group then there
should be pretty strict measures around
potential exposure and so for your
grandma to be concerned is correct like
my mom is in her 70s and we're very very
concerned about her too and so she
should still be adopting many of the
quarantine measures and expect that if
she wants to avoid people like that you
know the local restaurants reopening
might not be something that she enjoys
for a while there some other countries
have done something which I think is
really smart which is that they they've
opened up certain hours for senior
citizens or people that are at higher
risk where it's like look our place is
ordinarily you know a little bit crowded
or whatever they're gonna be these
periods of time where it's just senior
citizens it's gonna be less crowded and
you don't have to worry about you know
running into some young dumb infectious
person who's gonna like you know so I
think and even then if I was your
grandma I probably would still skip that
place because I'd be like I don't trust
that senior citizens things but that's
but that's a reasonable measure if
you're vulnerable in high-risk you know
you should still be operating very
similarly to the way you are right now
yeah I mean it's tough to say this in
hindsight but you know I wish this was
happening in a year that wasn't an
election year in the sense that if Trump
in the administration knew that they had
two more years to recover from this
that's an easy recovery story you lock
down as long as you think is needed and
you can ride out the economic wave that
will come inevitably if we open up the
economy again right now I just feel so
politicized you know we're not thinking
long-term we're not thinking the benefit
of people's lives or think about the
benefit of an administration I want stay
in power and the Democrats probably
would do a similar thing if they were in
power too sadly it's the probably the
nature of the game I don't know if you
have thoughts on that but you know I
think that I think we'd be in the
similar spot regard
of the the timing of the election in the
sense that you you know we can't all
stay inside until as a vaccine and
regardless of the political backdrop
that would be the case so we're gonna
have to start making tougher choices and
that to me the path to making better
tougher choices is more testing more
data more information and that would
also bolster confidence so much it's
like one of the big problems we're all
having is like hey if I go out and I go
shopping or you know I mean where I am
is not it's not open so it's like but if
I want to consider going to a restaurant
like how do I know what the heck is
going on
like I don't you know it's like I you
know in and this is apples to oranges
but in South Korea they're literally
getting alerts on their phone saying
like hey there's like a patient like 20
miles behind you that's convert they
confirmed coronavirus they even have
like general descriptions of the person
[Music]
you know so on one hand that's like off
the intrusive in distopian on the other
hand it would give you more confidence
about going out because you'd be like
well it seems like we actually know when
someone gets sick and or is infectious
or high-risk and they're actually like
trying to trace who the persons come
into contact with in a way that here we
we have no idea about so you you talk
about that with Ian you know where
you're like the surveillance societies
and surveillance countries are already
recovering because and this isn't I'm
not something you recommended but they
were covering because they know what
everybody's doing and where they're at
and what exactly they're spending the
money on and what they're eating and all
those things and it's working for them
well the tough thing is we pretty much
missed that window it's like it only
tried to do it now would be like you
know be a total fiasco disaster though
we should still be doing some more data
gathering in different ways yes
so but there was like a window of
opportunity that we missed ma'am like
China was the example you need and
talked about where they're actually
recovering
the South Korea is the best example I
mean they'd have they went hard and they
were covering - the president's been
kind of and the administration's kind of
been ranting on the China aspect of
coronavirus and you've been on record
saying you can be angry at China and
hold them accountable without being
racist towards Chinese Americans and
then Donald's been doing this really
interesting thing he said there's a lot
of angry Chinese Americans like you
tweeted this out a lot of angry Chinese
Americans and they should be angry but
then he keeps calling it the great China
plague so it's like literally both sides
of his mouth I think you could have a
very and should have and hopefully have
a very strong role to play in this
election as a voice of reason as an
Asian American leader thoughts on this
or where's your head at around the China
buyers aspect of coronavirus no Asian
Americans are angry that Americans are
dying and that America is number one in
cases and deaths and that we're all
faced with this this economic
catastrophe this public health
catastrophe that has been made
significantly worse by terrible
leadership so that's what pisses us off
the most as human beings and Americans
and you know like and and it's really
important to distinguish between the
Chinese government Chinese people
Chinese Americans and Asian Americans
were all very different sets of people
but really the fact of the matter is
like the genesis of this crisis is at
this point like not front and center for
like you know 99% of Americans like
we're worried about our own health our
families like our mental health our
frontline health care workers like our
mothers and fathers and grandmas and
like all that like that's what we care
about you know it's like saber rattling
at China like does not make anyone
healthier does not get us more tests
does not get us better data to make
better
decisions and not reopen our schools you
know it's like any time he talks about
this it's just to distract from their
watching the handling of the the crisis
it's like you know like yeah like it's
their fault it's like the entire worlds
in this mess like do you think every
governments just running around saying
like blame them while people die I mean
it's really you know it's just like it
it doesn't speak to what we actually
care about right it's I think it's hard
to see I think in policing the history
books I was taught to read from American
presidents have we've elected strong
leaders generally speaking and the
president even if you disagree their
policies and so it's usually the story
women toll is American leadership
stepping up in times of crisis and I
feel like we're not doing that right now
and that is the hardest part
to watch and frankly suffer the
consequences from you know as a person
oh oh we're doing it but the leaders are
literally like the nurses and the I mean
it's really heartbreaking it's like the
you know and it's not obviously
unfortunately like you know it'd be much
better to have an appropriate
coordinated federal response than just
leaving it frontline workers and states
to essentially be trying to solve this
themselves yeah speaking of leadership
and states and cities we won our lawsuit
for those of you care against the New
York Board of Elections congratulations
Andrew yes one in O in lawsuits thus far
though they are appealing so we'll see
you are appealing we're gonna count it I
I'm pretty sure I mean heck the federal
judge saw it pretty cut-and-dried and
you know you objectively eliminating
people's right to vote is legal loser
you know it's like that's pretty
straightforward and common sense yeah
and for those of you who care about
these sort of things this is teeing up
an improbable shocking run for New York
City Mayor may be no comment from Andrew
yang I find that answer
we'll see TV I will say I've seen the
polls and you can't see my shit-eating
grin but I have a shit-eating grin after
looking at polls so you know it's an
interesting option you know I'll say I'm
focused on helping Joey win right now I
mean that's job one and same here I'm
focused on that and making snide
comments about the mayor race that way
alright so just the topic of the New
York race yeah there's one major
variable for whoever the next mayor is
gonna be and that's the level of federal
aid New York City gets I mean that
they're gonna have a hole in their
budget of billions tens of billions of
dollars over time I think is eight
billion dollars right now and so if the
city of New York is going to have a
chance at bouncing back then they're
going to need lots of federal help and
that's appropriate because they pay a
ton in in taxes and they're a huge
economic driver and it's the right thing
to do right I feel like we can do a
whole episode on your political future
and I'd love to do it now another time
so tune in yang speaks you never know
will drop all of Yang's political
aspirations which I will tell you some
things that with Andrew a lot they are
you're indifferent about a lot of
politics Andrew you just want to solve
problems it's usually good alright guys
so thanks so tuning we've got Van Jones
today van I'm sorry I ever doubted you
or ever hated on you before this episode
has changed the way I looked at you
Angie was pretty indifferent and now he
loves you or maybe he always has loved
you but for those of you didn't know Van
Jones you will look him different after
this episode Van Jones joins yang speaks
[Music]
[Applause]
then how are you doing brother
you are maybe the og charter member of
the yang gang that may be among people
who are on TV for a living though I know
you do a lot of other things that's not
like your Olympic but now I'm on TV for
living among other things and yeah it
was it was so nuts because I think part
of what happened when you came on the
scene is that some of us were really
looking not toward DC for answers but
we're looking you know more toward
Silicon Valley and other places for
answers and they're you know the math
was obvious you know the destruction of
jobs robots all that sort of stuff
massive conversation on the west coast
where I live half the time and then in
DC you know the question was you know do
you hate immigrants or billionaires and
so you know you have this completely
stupid conversation everything in DC in
this really bright conversation
happening on the west coast and then
suddenly you know you bridge the gap and
I was jumping up and down so happy about
it people were like you be what ub40
isn't that a break a group like what do
you know you bi anyway so just be aware
that you know I was looking for you
before you showed up and I sure was glad
when you did well thank you van I know
you took a lot of heat for it from some
of your colleagues at CNN where they
were like man what the heck is going on
like it was like a running joke why are
you standing so hard for this young guy
he's got no shot like what do you do it
man I mean listen I told you last time I
saw a couple weeks ago I said you know
you know how T one else's train you know
this is the train that the you know the
Pope just came out the Pope is coming
out for your ideas I think you won you
might not have won the primary but you
won the Pope and that's a bigger deal
well thank you man you know the fact
that you see things differently than a
lot of folks who hang out in DC doesn't
surprise me given where you came from in
your back
is fascinating you grew up in Tennessee
and then you end up going to law school
in New Haven Connecticut I mean that
must have been some kind of crazy
culture shock I could not understand 20%
of the words that my fellow students
were using in casual conversation you
know that's a oh well you seem to be
here for egalitarian reasons and what
you're saying is paradigmatic I said
what what I mean I would have to ask
them what do you mean over and over and
over again and I had to tell him I've
never heard of brown I've never heard of
Princeton I think I heard of Oxford I
thought it was in Boston you guys think
that the whole world revolves around you
most people live their whole life
we don't know we've never heard of
Andover none of these places and they're
very smart people who are doing a
brilliant job making America work every
day and we don't know anything about you
and I you know discovered in myself this
view and actually as my father he said
look you know these kids are ahead of
you you know they leave lately they know
a lot of stuff you don't know but they
know it for only one reason they've read
a lot of books and they've had a lot of
conversations you haven't had yet you
can read those books you can have those
conversations you can know what they
know but they will never know what you
know they will never ever know what you
know because you know where you've grown
up where you're from what you've seen
they're never gonna see that and so once
you catch them you're gonna be fine this
reminds me of the book hillbilly elegy
by JD Vance whichever you read another
yeah yeah and it's the the other version
of this where it's the guy from
Appalachia was in the military went to a
believer's Ohio State and then went to
Yale and also had that fish-out-of-water
culture shock what the heck is going on
yeah why is there so much silverware who
are you people
why do you have like in his case do it
was like why does the fact that I was in
the military make you think like all
these strange things about me that like
many of which are not you know
wholeheartedly positive and and there
was like that culture shock confusion
between you know the way the vast
majority of people live which the vast
majority of people live in the way that
you did in Tennessee or the way that JD
Vance did in Ohio like you know they're
not hanging out at like the like the
Yale auditoriums yeah and the crazy
thing about it was I was used to people
having to earn their way I mean you know
you show up and you got to work your
butt off the first day of class we're in
the auditorium the Dean comes out and he
starts talking about how you know among
you or will be senators among you will
be Supreme Court justices among you may
be a president I states I'm like we
don't even know where the restrooms are
so like nobody here has proven [ __ ] so I
don't know why but you know it was
shocking to me the level of just a
sumption of privilege and entitlement if
you pass these tests and got enrolled
here you're gonna run the country and
you know by the way a couple of my
classmates are in the US and we were
classmates class schoolmates were in the
US Senate right now and a couple ran for
president so listen he was right and I
was wrong
but I think for ordinate what I'm so
glad about and you know you seem to have
some of this as well you talk to enough
regular people it puts all that stuff in
perspective it's a very small group of
people that in almost the same school to
know each other and have the same kind
of blind spots that have way too much
power at least positionally in the
country when the fact that that dude was
right
you know factually years and years later
is that even a good thing know you'd
like make that presumption of being like
well somebody here is gonna be a senator
it's like what the [ __ ] have you done
like the people that that's going to be
qualified to make our nation's decisions
chest you wrote some papers you pass
some tests you got accepted to a fancy
school that really should be you know at
best the starting point but you know it
was it wasn't end and that's why I think
what your movement is doing is about
it's so important you know when you have
this much concentration of not just
power but but axe
and privilege and standing it's such a
small tiny number of hands at the very
very top you're gonna have rebellions at
the bottom now it may be right-wing
populism you know saying we hate the
immigrants
it could be left wing populism saying
yeah we hate the billionaires but you're
gonna have a rebellion the question is
can you have a positive populism can you
have a populist they say let's empower
everybody let's respect everybody but we
don't have to disrespect or hate anybody
to be a part of it and really through in
the Western world your movement is that
positive populist and I was looking for
us like this guy is able to point out
the real pain of what's going on for
people but he doesn't have to demonize
anybody listen the system is
malfunctioning we need to redesign it so
it includes more people and it counts
for the real threats which are you know
robots and artificial intelligent part
of the conversation so look I just think
you did the country a great favor I
think you're at the very beginning of
you know I mean both parties stealing
all your ideas and that kind of stuff
but the reality is that the people are
not wrong the establishment yeah the
people are not wrong yeah people are
actually really freaking smart yeah they
look up and be like hey things are not
working the things you're talking about
have nothing to do with anything in my
life why are you having the same stupid
food fights about nonsense that no one I
know cares about like that the anger is
just growing because of the disconnect
and uh and the thing that I started
recognizing okay Obama should the to the
establishment Obama came out of nowhere
and just shocked everybody all Hillary
Clinton's gonna win it's not gonna win
nothing and then out of it then here
comes a Tea Party out of nowhere oh my
God we're so shocked to see the Tea
Party and then it was Occupy Wall Street
these guys came out of nowhere
and there was black lives matter he's
got come out nowhere I said maybe
nowhere is a lot bigger than you think
it is you know anything maybe maybe no
where is the vast majority of people
maybe nowhere is everywhere everywhere
[Laughter]
but yeah I just even that kind
you know that language it just lets you
know where who they think matters and
who they think counts if you if you eat
in York Times you listen to NPR and you
pay attention to CNN and MSNBC then you
know you are smart if you eat at Waffle
House you know if you get your news you
know through your church networks and
and that kind of stuff if you went to
public schools then you're done but
those are the people who keep driving
these movements that keep knocking them
on their butts I was a very nerdy kid I
loved getting books at those little book
clubs that we had in our schools you
know what I don't know if you all
remember what I'm talking about anyway
today what is that book Club of the 21st
century I'm happy to say that there's a
company now literati that's a godsend
for parents like me who have young kids
where you're trying to find good books
for your kids that are age-appropriate
and educational but you don't have that
much time you're not exactly going to
become an expert in kids books at least
I'm not so what do we do we subscribe to
literati which then sends you books for
your kids the number one book club for
kids and here's the kicker if you don't
dig the books you actually can send them
back can you believe that it's nuts
each literati box contains five books
based on a theme and a personalized note
to your child so it seems like someone
actually cares about your child anyway
so if this sounds good to you it's like
a personalized book club for your kids
where they'd use get sent books it makes
you feel like a good parent you can read
that book to your with your child they
can read it on their own if they can
read which my kids one of them can't
and so that's literati what a great
freaking idea it started by some awesome
entrepreneurs I love this thing to death
you're gonna love it too
and if you want to get 25% off your
first two orders just go to literati
dot-com slash yang best offer available
anywhere go to literati comm slash yang
for 25% off your first two orders
that's Li ter ATI if you don't know how
to spell literati you're literally not
literati if you can't spell literati but
its literati comm slash yang get some
books for your kids
they will then learn to read and then
eventually make you proud I want to say
two things that are like that I just
want you know I think you're really
interesting there was first I'm gonna
relate my equivalent to your law school
experience which was like very very
different yet the same and so let me
explain that so my parents immigrated
here from Taiwan and they arrived here
as graduate students at Berkeley so then
they met had me my brother and I ended
up at a fancy law school really just on
the basis of the fact that I was good at
tests and so I showed up and then
everyone was like you guys are gonna go
do something and I'm like all right we
haven't done [ __ ] to deserve that and
and I was a kid who actually went
straight from college to law school so I
was literally 21 to me to to showing up
and then I get a six-figure job offer
from a law firm because you know you're
I mean you know I was top of my class
you know at in law school but it you
don't need to be top of the class it's
like you know you're the average student
there you're getting like a job offer at
the same level and it shocked me because
I was like wait a minute I'm like 20 at
the time I was like 23 24
my dad has a PhD in physics from
Berkeley generated dozens of pens and
I'm all of a sudden making more than him
that despite the fact that like he's
like 1 million times more productive
yeah than I am and then I saw the nature
of the work I was doing at the firm and
I was like a barnacle on these
transactions you know it was like there
there's look like I was like like this
transaction cost like a spot of grease
it's like pay the spot of grease you
know a hundred forty thousand dollars to
just like lubricate and and and it just
seemed so messed up and wrong and I was
like you know like I'm cool with making
money but I should have done something
to deserve it other than get my hand
stamped it's like let me try and build
something let me start a business and so
I left to start a business that failed
and then I ended up you know trying to
learn and get better but I arrived at
that sense of that auditorium of
entitlement from like a different angle
and then recoiled from it in a different
way well you know it's it's I think a
lot of you know what's missing for the
leadership class and listen I don't mean
to sound ungrateful or arrogant I mean I
I I wouldn't trade my life for anything
I'm the things I've got chance to do and
you know working for Obama working for
Prince you know teaching at Princeton
yeah I've got a chance to do a bunch of
cool stuff I just never believed the
hype that I was somehow radically
smarter than the people working in the
cafeteria or radically smarter than the
security got off you know security
guards I thought like I was radically
luckier and now it's it's like a
particular narrow form of intelligence -
yes it's like we've got a lot of [ __ ]
dumb smart people in this country and a
disproportionate number of them worked
for Hillary Clinton in 2016 it's called
them data dummies I mean they were they
were really really smart and really
really dumb at the same time and when
people like myself who I mean I was
going out I was talk to people in
Pennsylvania I was talking to people in
Michigan I was talking to people in the
Rust Belt and I would go talk to these
guys now I would say listen you got a
bunch of problems here number one people
don't like a candidate they just don't
but number two the african-american
community is not getting the same
of support at the grassroots that Obama
gave and so I talked to this black
preacher after was over and I said well
you know the you know the data showed
the black we're gonna come out for
Hillary Clinton in very large numbers he
said data data don't vote data don't
vote people vote and if you don't put
money in the grassroots and help people
turn that vote out data is not gonna
save you that's what I'm saying and
that's what I think you see yes we need
data but we also need wisdom we got a
society now we got a super abundance of
data and very little wisdom at the top
Oh No so there is a article I read that
I found fascinating there was this
really really bright kid he was in Texas
and he got into some Ivy League school
and was set to go and then was not able
to go because of his immigration status
like that there was like a problem you
know in the Trump era I believe and so
he started to work in a Walmart in
retail and then so he's 8 to 18 working
in Walmart and then fast forward a few
years he ended up becoming like an
organizer of the people in that
community and like it sound like a
spokesperson like leading people that
are like twice his age and the rest of
this thing and what what hit me about
this story van was like I feel like our
elite educational systems actually
sucking people like that up into it so
let's say that kid instead of working at
Walmart and then ending up becoming a
labor organizer in Texas got into Yale
right like and then after Yale what's he
gonna do he's gonna become a management
consultant or investment banker or like
maybe right now we might work at a tech
company or something is he gonna go back
to rural Texas and become like an
organizer yeah probably not
and and so to me that there's been this
relationship where were acculturating
people with certain qualities into this
system of institutions that really
doesn't change a damn thing and and this
is one reason why Pete Budaj is getting
beaten up for working at McKinsey after
Harvard it's like like people who
understand it's like freaking like every
Harvard grad
it's over b2b like what the heck is
going on I was like McKinsey also known
as the fourth and fifth year at Harvard
but but then you know from the outside
looking in you're like wait a minute
like Mackenzie's like the the temple of
optimization for like these firms and
then there's this instinct that you
understand that that optimization does
not end up benefiting everyday men and
women workers very much and there's an
increasing understanding that our system
of elite institutions also does not
benefit like the everyday
momdad kid family worker but you know
it's like like all of our institutions
are designed to make things more
efficient and there's this mistaken
notion that's like oh if you make things
more efficient then people will benefit
it's like well actually if you make some
of these organizations more efficient
they're gonna fire tens hundreds of
thousands of people and maybe that's not
great for them like maybe that their
factory closing their factory getting
automated their Main Street stores
getting closed for Amazon like maybe
that's not great like even if they can
get some stuff cheaper online
no we're hyper efficient at some things
and woefully inefficient at other things
that are much much more important I mean
it's one reason why I ran for president
is that I realized that the biggest
problems were non market-based problems
like if you're trying to deliver an app
to my smartphone that's really really
efficient because there's money involved
in their firms that are like I'm gonna
try and make as much money as possible
that if it's how do I care for grandma
how to make our kids strong and healthy
how to heal the planet
those things are non-market they're not
market-based problems and they're
incredibly unfortunately right now not
even like on the radar or and and the
the thing I was saying on the trail all
the time is like look you have record
high GDP profitability of firms capital
efficiency and you also have record high
suicide despair
financial and security depression
anxiety drug abuse and and overdoses
record low levels of business formation
among young people marriage and and
childbearing if you see those as signs
of societal health which I happen to and
and so it's like so we're really
efficient at a certain set of activities
that have increasingly a negative
relationship with how we're doing yeah
you know and it's so like if we will
stay on that trail like where the heck
does it lead and to me the opportunity
through of this virus is to advance
bigger solutions because of what you
just described man where you know people
are at home and hopefully able to
reflect on frankly the ridiculousness of
a lot of the structures and incentives
we follow every day where everyone's
just been trained to say it's like you
know you're an input into the machine
and if you're breaking that's your fault
it's not anyone else faults like sure
we're all stressed out but you know
embrace the grind or like I'm doing it
hopefully there will be a giant
rebuilding process that follows this
crisis when we all emerge and certainly
I want to be part of that I know you
want to be part of that we've actually
had conversations about that before this
one about what the heck yeah the rebuild
looks like
[Music]
okay so I launched a podcast and then
someone sends me an electric scooter and
then I ride it around on it and it is
glorious holy crap
ooh now I use like the Tesla of electric
scooters and I don't say that lightly
it's called the unagi which is a little
bit of a weird name I think it means eel
in Japanese don't I eat Nagi rolls but
this unagi scooter freakin jams I gotta
say it makes just buzzing around so much
fun I've ridden scooters obviously
unlike those bird in lime and like uber
scooters and this is a step up from that
nothing against those scooters but this
thing is just better and cooler and so
much fun so if you want to see what I'm
talking about you can check them out and
get yours at unagi scooters calm that's
un AGI scooters calm and if you use the
discount code yang you get $150 off the
unagi
500 and holy crap this thing will change
your life because it's just so much
freaking fun like you just feel like
you're in the future like an episode of
Westworld like just cruising around but
the good you know like the good episodes
right you know what I mean it's also
environmentally friendly it's electric
you know you just go in someplace you're
not using much juice and this is fun as
hell they send you this scooter in a box
it takes 60 seconds to put it together
and then it's one snap put it away long
charge goes like 15 miles
I was zooming around the neighborhood
it's fantastic my sister videotaped me
Andrew Evelyn's video tape you you look
pretty badass too when you're riding
that thing you know well people are
trying to figure out what the hell it is
at first because you know they're like
is that a normal scooter and then they
realize that's not if you're in the
market for the scooter this thing hauls
ass and is awesome you nagi scooters
calm UN AGI scooters calm use the code
yang get $150 off for the Nagi e500
look like a badass feel like a badass
like a magic carpet it's awesome well
one of the things that we had a
conversation about is that when we were
talking about like establishment
non-establishment and you were like look
by virtue of just sitting in this room
with these TV cameras on like we're all
establishment like there's no way to
avoid it and I know that for me that was
something that was like new or a bit of
a struggle because to me it's like look
if I have an opportunity to get my ideas
out there to the American people in a
way that helps normalize them like
that's a win but you and I both know
that there are many Americans who
mistrust anyone who's near the levers or
part of the establishment and there's
like this real resistance that in some
ways I really understand because it's
like like would I trust these people
well [ __ ] like things have been going
pretty poorly for me in mind for a long
last time and as soon as someone's
interests seem to be in preserving the
status quo and not shakin the boat too
much like you know maybe I need to look
elsewhere
so I actually completely get that while
also in my mind it's like it's a an
absolute good to try and acclimate
Americans to my perspective oh really
just my face and voice because we have a
freaking president now in the White
House that just got there through being
familiar to Americans or being a
celebrity being like you're fired all
that that apprentice [ __ ] so people
listen I I understand like there's a in
everything you have like the purists and
the pragmatists and yeah even you know
in skateboarding culture it's like oh
you're not really down you know like you
like it you know and hip-hop you're not
really really know hip-hop hit so in
every culture or subculture you have the
purest versus the pragmatist but I think
what people have to understand is that
the time scale that we have to move if
we're going to avoid an ecological
catastrophe if we're going to preserve
them
cursey if we're gonna have any kind of
shot at social you know remotely fair I
mean remotely fair social order is very
short I mean we don't very short you
don't have 30 years we do not have a lot
of time at all and so and and the thing
that I you know I try explaining people
is Fame is a hack for time fame is a
hack for time if I have to sit up here
and explain to you well I know this
woman and she's a very good person she's
you know very beautiful she's married to
a hip-hop person she's you know good
entrepreneur if I could just say
Kardashian you know exactly what I'm
talking about it took me three seconds
and then I can move on with the
conversation so being well-known in an
economy that's we're basically time and
attention are the biggest commodities
like the most precious thing of money
there's a lot of money you can't get to
a half time you got tons of money even
rich people though are time poor the
richest people in the world are some of
the most time poor and so if you have to
deal with that condition of the digital
civilization you live in and Fame is
just a hack for time so I can now say
yang gang on a subway and everybody
knows what I'm talking about and that's
for me useful um the more people who
know about you the easier my job is
because I'm trying to promote positive
solutions and yet there's this you know
worship of attention and celebrity and
also an understandable fear of it
because it can be corrupting it can be
isolating it does make you know my life
is very different now that I'm a
relatively well-known person at least
among news nerds than it was before you
know and so yes it there's a danger
there but the bigger danger is that
people with great ideas never get heard
because we are only willing to speak you
know to our own small Twitter followings
and in our own Facebook groups and we're
just afraid to walk on that big stage
and I think that hey listen if you
create a situation where there's some
you know younger fresher more edgy less
you know CN n ready voices but are still
in harmony then the movement continues
to grow
some people are more disaffected with
you but like other people who are like
you who are just maybe a little bit more
you know you know grassroots but listen
I don't think that people like you can
afford to keep your light under a bushel
I think you know people like you who've
got a big heart and a big brain and a
good message and good values we need you
to have more attention bigger platforms
the people who are the [ __ ] the
people who are really I mean there are
people in this world who were really
just out for themselves or who really
just don't care or who actually just
mean those people never shrink from the
opportunity to grab the microphone and
so therefore I think it's important for
other people to have an equal and fair
shot yeah to me we just need to get the
job done and whatever tools come my way
to get the job done like I'm all for
yeah like if someone who's been bashing
me at a particular point in time then
like comes around later I'm just like
cool let's do it you know when I left
the Obama White House under fire you
know I had been such a radical firebrand
in my 20s and 30s I was considered a
left-wing radical in the Bay Area now
you have to work hard to distinguish
yourself in the Bay Area as a left
winger but I did it but when the deal
goes down and we had a chance to pass a
criminal justice reform bill in 2018 I
worked hand-in-hand with Mark Holden
from Koch Industries hand-in-hand with
Jared Kushner and stood in the Oval
Office with Donald Trump when he signed
the bill and I'm literally an arm's
length away from Mike Pence and we're
giving each other the thumbs up because
I'm like you I just want to get it done
like as tough as it was for me to get
run out of the Obama White House as
awful as I thought I had been treated
when I left I got another job and my
life went on and other people don't have
jobs and don't have any you know obvious
shot and so whether it's on the left you
know so then I had people on the left
attacking me for working with Trump and
that's it what would you rather have
Donald Trump for criminal justice reform
or against it do you want Donald Trump
to be out here saying keep everybody in
prison keep
everybody in prisons I gotta make your
life better or would you rather him say
you know what now Republic the Democrats
can work together on this I think it
makes a lot better this one there's one
thing there's one disagree on many other
things we can fight on everything else
and we do but on this one thing you know
for people behind bars nobody behind
bars is mad that the president is now
more on there so there's one out yeah
that's like is yeah they don't care
who's in the White House they want to go
home for their mom's house so you know
you just got you know a whole different
I think approach to politics and to life
you know Andrew that I think has just
been a godsend I think it's very you
know similar to mine it's why I'm a part
of yanking yeah let's put real people
first let's get real stuff done we can
fight about some skill a let's let's
fight from 9:00 to noon and then fight
again from like 1:00 to 5:00 but can
from noon to 1:00 we get something done
like that's all I'm not I'm not asking
for a lot I'm just saying just for one
hour a day can we actually get something
done and you know I think I think if
more people have that attitude we get a
lot more stuff done that's that's very
profound man that's very profound
because one of the things I found
frustrating about this realm is that
there's this focus on appearance over
substance or appearance over reality and
if you run a business your reality based
all the time for an organization your
reality based all the time and I've said
before that running for president slike
an exercise and terrible leadership in
many ways because if you had a leader
who was just running after TV cameras
all the time being like here's what I
think here's what I think like you know
things are probably going very poorly
for that person's company or
organization but there's a lot of wisdom
in what you're saying where there
probably is actually some kind of
balance a middle ground
[Music]
alright guys this podcast is sponsored
by helix sleep which provides mattresses
so if you are so bored by this
conversation we did y'all solid and got
you discount on a bed and what's pretty
awesome about helix frankly is they have
this customized survey to fill out and
quiz to take to figure out what type of
bed you prefer and then they customize
it to you so if you sweat at night if
you move around a lot if you have lower
back discomfort upper back you like
being on angle you like it cool like hot
whatever it is you fill it out it's
pretty quick and they customize mattress
for you it's a phone half coils it's
pretty remarkable and one of the coolest
things I found is they ship it in a box
to you so you can get anywhere for me in
living in New York City it's just a tiny
little thing that I can get shipped my
apartment I can bring it in without
having to get delivery guys and etc I
think I need a helix sleep mattress Zak
as my back hurts from carrying this
podcast I'm gonna need one of those
pillows to cry into after that
awarded the number one best overall
mattress of 2019 and 2020 by GQ and
wired you go to helix sleep comm slash
yang take their quiz they'll match you
with a customized mattress get a 10 year
warranty and they're offering up to $200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix sleep
comm slash yang that's helix h e li x
sleep comm slash yang for up to $200 off
so Zack you sweat a lot when you sleep
that's that's not cool that's a little
too much
it depends man I mean the eight I had a
while my AC was breaking and then yeah I
would have been helpful to have a
mattress that had a hot sleeper if you
will but we've put in the mat we're
putting that in yet probably well helix
sleep calm slash yang get 200 bucks off
and they're thrown in two free pillows
if you're in the market for a mattress
helix sleep comm slashing
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the ideas that I read that struck
me was was from you've all know a
Ferrari where he talked about how
everyone thinks that oh they're these
people pulling the strings at the top
but really the problem is that no one
even knows where the power went legally
the power has disappeared and you get
there you're like where is the power
where is the power and so when you're on
the outside looking in it's very easy to
imagine there is this a cabal or
Illuminati and like they're making all
this stuff happen but to me the real
danger is that just the entire machinery
is so weak that and we're seeing it
right now when the pandemics here it's
like okay like let's get some checks out
let's get some testing done let's like
try and support businesses in various
ways that's good and then you look at
some gloves and masks and nurses yeah
let's get some gloves and master nurses
something really basic you know and and
then you see we're struggling to do that
eat every one of the things I just
listed and you're just like okay like
you know why are we so lousy at doing
things that seem like they should be
relatively straightforward and so that
to me is really the concern is that we
we have this the set of deteriorating
institutions and there are people who
are part of these institutions that in
many ways their interests are served by
pretending like the institutions still
work and the institutions have been
getting weaker the whole time people are
looking around being like I don't think
this is working so well and to the
extent the institution even as supposed
to help people it turns out I'm not one
of the help ease so now I'm increasingly
hostile towards institutions and so like
that is actually to me the bigger set of
concerns and we're seeing it right now
like you look around and you're and and
to me climate change is another very big
example where clearly it's it's this
massive world threatening species
threatening problem and sure they're
definitely corrupt corporate interests
on the other end of it just trying to
maximize their profits and saying you
know
I'd rather not have to deal with
regulation in these particular areas so
that's definitely happening but the the
problem really is that we don't have the
strength in our government to be able to
one override those corporate interests
but to do all these things that we all
feel like we would need to do if we're
going to preserve our planet for our
kids the next generation so I'm with you
that that the institutional mistrust in
some ways is missing like the core
problem which is just that the
institution's actually don't have the
wherewithal to perform their functions
well I tell you what having been you
know inside of a bunch of white houses
and you know like I said I I you know I
went to a fancy law school I was a
fellow at MIT of you know there's I've
been on the I've been a grassroots
outsider and I've also been a White
House insider I've been a target of the
media now a part of the mainstream media
I grew up in a red state
I've got educated in a blue coasts I I
can tell all the time there's nobody
driving the bus
there's nobody flying the plane it's
much worse than you think you think
there's a bunch of mean people up there
who know what they're doing and who are
getting away with murder there's a bunch
of people out there who don't know what
they're doing and are getting away with
murder that's much worse it's not that
they're me it's like literally like it's
just it's chaos and so what that to me
suggests though you know once you once
you pull the curtain back in The Wizard
of Oz and you realize even the wizard
that you thought had all this power is
you know posturing you do have to look
within and it turns out you know Dorothy
hat the slippers the whole time it turns
out that you know we had each other the
whole time like the wisdom is out here
you know the the genius is out here the
power is out here the power is in the
hands of the powerless it's the people
who are not stuck in these systems and
trying to pretend like everything is
cool they have the ability to think new
thoughts trying new things you've seen
all these mass movements come sweeping
out of quote-unquote nowhere battering
the establishment the past ten years I
think the question is you know can you
put the smart
with the heart you know can you be you
know having the data and the wisdom can
you put the smart with the heart and
then can you put you know great ideas
with great people so that you can
actually start getting stuff done you
know the other thing that I'm concerned
about really is the the formation of
what comes next is that if you have this
discontent with our current structures
which I think you're right people will
have to higher and higher degrees as a
result of this time the question really
is how do you build the new structures
that would be superior and that one's
very very hard I mean they like the the
basic ones staring at us is like we have
this two-party system we have a
government that has failed us in many
respects like during this time and so
how do you build a new and better
government and that's something that
people have been struggling with for
decades I certainly think that that is
the project of this era and that I want
to do it like I'm into it but I also
know what that would mean like that that
would mean a political revolution that
would mean different leaders with
different outlooks and and philosophies
than the ones that we're currently
getting so I hope that very positive
things come out of this era but no I I
believe that it's going to be a really
really fraught difficult arduous process
to try and build something positive out
of it look I agree with that I mean in
some ways the floor has been torn out
from under us and that's where the the
fear comes and the scary part comes even
politically you know democracy our
democratic republic is the hardest form
of government to keep and the hardest
one to establish I mean see it means the
easiest one to lose and the hardest one
to establish and so so in some ways the
floor has been torn out from under us
but also the ceiling has been torn out
off from over us I don't think that a
lot of people are gonna be shocked if
somebody comes forward and says hey we
need a very different approach here
and so yeah we can fall or fly you know
kind of based on our own efforts and you
know it's hard it's easier to fall into
fly but I do think that you know this
there's definitely gonna be openness to
more different stuff yeah and like the
this most straightforward example is
that there was the magical Asian man
going around saying I want you get a
thousand bucks a month and then people
were like oh that's impossible and then
now tens of millions of people just got
$1,200 literally today like I actually
that was possible it's like maybe we can
start to think bigger
listen I mean your ideas were nowhere on
the map a year ago in from the
establishments point of view and now you
know the president and the Pope were
both with you that's pretty good for
twelve months and so who knows what next
twelve months will be it could be bad
but yeah could be really good too it's
time brother
yeah like to me universal basic income
is the foundation of the floor and then
we have to build this glorious structure
on top of it and it's gonna include a
lot of things but you and I are going to
be there
God willing both both making the plans
for the structure and then God willing
building it so thank you for being such
an awesome friend and champion to me and
the yang gang before it was cool it took
a lot of heat but like you said like you
know you you're not afraid of a fight no
and it seems like you have a record of
being way ahead of the curve so well
look I mean that the to charitable
organizations I'm most committed to
there's Reform Alliance calm we don't
take a lot of donations but we sure need
people to sign up so Reform Alliance
comm started by jay-z and Meek Mill and
Robert Smith and Robert Kraft a bunch of
people but reform alliance calm is
important to me also cut fifty.org CU t
cuts 55 0 org needs a lot of money a lot
of help
it's the biggest grassroots network in
the country of bipartisan criminal
justice reform errs people who've been
you know fighting to try from a
bottom-up left and right together trying
to get prisons to be smaller and smarter
they need a lot of money right now
because of this virus just tearing up
the prisons
so cut fifty.org is the other place I
care a lot about wealth congratulations
man such awesome organizations and
awesome work we definitely need more of
it really appreciate the heck out of you
man I learned from you every time I took
some time and I ventured into the
comment section of Twitter the other day
you guys have a lot of opinions about
our podcasts so we'd love to hear from
you we'd love to answer your questions
go ahead and just use the hashtag ask
yang speaks for a question you'd like
answered and then we will hunt it down
and answer them hopefully not all of
them but some of them we might even
devote a whole episode to it that would
be a lot of fun that would be fun so
hashtag ask yang speaks do it on Twitter
do it on Instagram we'll try and find it
too we'll try and search and comb
through all of it and pull the good ones
to make a good episode thanks guys
[Music]